salut bande de petits veinards que vous
êtes aujourd'hui je vous explique une
astuce de mentalisme pour bluffer les
gens mais qui est à la table et ça on
aime
oui on aime je trouve ça super important
vous faire la démonstration avant que
vous puissiez voir l'impact et la
puissance que sarah quand vous essayer
de bluffer quelqu'un avec alors oui on
n'est plus sûr de la magique du
mentalisme comme tout ce qui est un rat
table d'ailleurs parce que mentalist est
jamais sûr à 100% mais je pense que vous
allez bien vous barrer avec sa
démonstration en est donc avec céline h
c'est moi de la chaîne céline h vous
narre fait une vidéo dans le milieu de
l'année ensemble on en a refait n'ya pas
l'enfant fait une vidéo on n'a pas fait
une vidéo de chez fela l'assistante un
peu potiche dit beaucoup aimer les
commentaires y ont dit mais c'est pas
possible la prochaine fois faut que tu
prennes quelqu'un qui fais pas la gueule
ouais j'ai autant celui à l'adage est
certes jeune mais je ne vais pas cesser
de sourire je vais te faire un tour ça
c'est le premier truc qui s en suit je
vais t'expliquer le tour je vais
t'apprendre à le faire je vais pouvoir
le faire moi même si le but c'est que
vous aussi vous puissiez apprendre à le
faire et en même temps peut-être que tu
vas avoir des problèmes à faire des
choses et dans ces cas là c'est des
problèmes qui pourrait peut-être avoir
eu sachant que tu as une capacité à
avoir des problèmes que tous ceux qui
comme moi ont une petite tendance aux
problèmes psychomoteurs rotation dans
l'espace rester car si moi j'y arrive
ça veut dire que vous y arriverez parce
que vraiment je suis au à le jeu tutoie
les étoiles entendre alors on a pris un
hubert ensemble tout le trajet elle
n'arrivait pas à enclencher la ceinture
mais c'était très très drôle à voir j'ai
regretté de pas avoir la caméra ce jour
là j'ai beaucoup ri oui et en fait je
l'avais et voici j'ai avec moi c'est de
petit carton sur lequel sont dessinés 1
0 c'est un test en fait c'est un test d'
analyse psychomoteur d'avoir c'est très
intéressant
il y en a 2 celui-ci jeunes mettent ici
va rester a vu tout le long vous pouvez
le surveiller tout le long et derrière
celui ci il ya des dessins des symboles
je te les faits pas voir à toi regarde
pas d'écran de retour je voulais fait
voir juste à vous pour le moment ce sont
des formes complètement bizarre
aléatoire un peu mystique qui vont
déterminer si le hasard psychomoteur
existe ou pas j'étais perdu tu arrêtes
tes commentaires
trop étrange là en clair derrière il ya
16 cases avec ses symboles et je vais
t'en faire choisir un de manière
aléatoire tu va compter c'est comme sur
un damier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ha ça va
je maîtrise et du contrat en partant de
la gauche vers la droite comme comme
quand on lit un livre ça va c'est bon là
c'est du noir charles et pour ça je te
demander de fermer les yeux tu laisses
passer les chiffres de 1 à 16 dans ta
tête et spontanément tu mens 10 1 entre
1 et 16,1 et 16 étant inclus je t'écoute
tu as choisi le 8 donc je veux juste
retourner le carton et tu vas comptèrent
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 6 pour voir les urnes ce
que les yeux fermés thierry va pas donc
juste je retourne et tu compte 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 % voilà donc je compte en moyenne
2 3 4 5 6 7 et 8
ok tu vois ce symbole là il est unique
tu le regardes le memri ge quels jeux
vous le fait de pouvoir aussi c'est le
symbole qui est juste là voilà ici là
vous le voyez bien ok tu aurais pu
choisir un des autres suivant le chiffre
que j'aurai choisi et ce petit carton
qui n'a pas bougé depuis le départ n'est
ce pas qui est juste là à un symbole lui
aussi tout particulier tu le vois dans
l'écran de retour mais non or c'est
exactement lèves et tu peux voir qu'ils
sont vraiment tous différents ninon et
on a fait exactement ce que je t'avais
annoncé au départ
dana moi je suis là pour garantir que
c'est bien le même avis et sa lumière le
8 mai en fin mai qu'elle échoue shore a
quand même bien ou pas c'est fait
et encore mais dans ces cas là j'ai
peut-être pas l'expliquer alors j'ai
peut-être le garder pour moi ouais dit
aussi sa partie se désabonnent alors
pour faire ce tour il faudrait donc ces
deux petits cartons oui qui sont
imprimés des deux côtés recto verso ça
pour être imprimée sur une feuille et
sachez déjà que dans la description vous
avez un pdf avec les fichiers pour
l'imprimé vous même mais vous pouvez
aussi avoir les versements ont cartonné
et ça je vous dirai comment à la fin en
suisse un pas qui nous importe c'est
celui ci comment il est construit donc
ces symboles différents originaux dessus
tracé de mes petits doigts musclés sur
photoshop je dessine comme un enfant de
5 ans on est d'accord il ya un moment où
je t'ai menti mais où je vous ai menti
c'est qu'il n'ya pas c'est ce symbole
différentes donc en fait celui ci est
celui ci est celui ci est celui ci c'est
le même mais il suffit de rotation de 90
degrés mais oui et comme c'est que des
formes très arrondies et très spéciale
sera pas compter celui ci c'est celui ci
c'est celui ci aussi et y en a un en bas
c'est celui là assez énorme
ils sont placés à des endroits vraiment
stratégique pour qu'en tournant de 90°
le carton tu vois il n'y a pas de haut
il n'y a pas de base dessus il n'y a pas
de gauche n'est pas de droite suivant
comment tu le tourner
tu vas réussir à couvrir les seize
possibilité de venir qu'au départ on
était comme ça oui
le huit est là mais si tu m'avais dit 2
par exemple j'aurais mis de carton comme
ça et là tu compte 1,2 et tu tombes
encore une fois sur le bon symbole sauf
qu'il est tournée de 90 degrés j'ai mis
des petits indices au dos c'est pour ça
que paul imprimé recto verso en haut il
ya marqué numéro 1 6 8 c 14 comme un
numéro de série
ça veut dire que si la personne 10 1 6 8
comme tafer ou 14
alors j'ai juste à retourner le carton
comme ça d'accord tu comprends le
principe s'agit donc si je dis ici s'il
faut retourner comment il faut retourner
comme ça exactement et de manière
naturelle
oui parce que là ça se voit ou alors je
me suis je peux prétendre que audi donc
comme la page d'un livre
oui exact attention dit un chiffre 6
si c'est vrai si la personne 10 1 6 8 ou
14 vous retourner comme ça ensuite il ya
la même astuce de tous les côtés tu me
dis comment toi aussi tu me dis quand je
vais trop vite pour ceux qui sont en bas
au lieu de retourner comme ça on va
retourner comme sa logique de bas vers
le haut ça j'ai compris si la personne
10 3 10 11 ou 16 retourner comme ça les
deux autres ceux des deux petits côtés
il ya une astuce pour qu'on ait l'air
naturel quand on les retourne un peu
comme toi là un peu comme moi là trois
fois qu'on fait la ga séquence parce que
je le beauf mais bon c'est de le prendre
en diagonale donc par des coins opposés
et de le tourner comme ça avec l'index
ou là ça c'est plus compliqué là c'est
plus compliqué et on va rigoler on se
souvient que j'ai du mal à attacher une
ceinture dans une voiture je jouissais
d'ivoire chiffre 4 au 10 donc voilà
exactement pas comme ça recommence comme
h près du shorty on y retourne pouces
hockey majeur
ok index rotatif exactement tu le tire
vers toi ton index maintenant tu viens
me l'enlever je sais moi non mais c'est
justement là au moins pour savoir si je
les comprends pas trop que j'ai c'est
dit c'est vrai oui je sais qu'il verra
tout index avec son tapis j'ai
apparemment j'avais trop petite voix et
attention exactement et tu leur pose à
plat 4 5 7 15 alors vous retourner comme
ça en diagonale et donc de la même
manière si c'est l'un des chiffres qui
est sur ce bord droit
on va faire la même chose mais avec
l'autre main allez petit bon chocolat
piment chaud on se prépare on fait comme
moi et on y arrivera donc pouces majeur
à mal
index exact rotatif wave asie
et hier le et pose le si la personne
10,2 10-12-13 vous retourne également en
diagonale mais avec la main gauche
l'autre main et que vous soyez droitier
ou gaucher cela n'a aucune espèce
d'importance puisque les gestes se
réalise naturellement dès demain juste
sa demande tout en s'entraînant soyons à
y aller
est-ce que tu le feras à des gens à moi
même déjà à toi non mais tu vas
t'entraîner doit s'entraîner c'est là
d'ailleurs moi même
ouais je vais moto et pathé après tout
ça de le faire à quelqu'un c'est cette
émission challenge à une annie d'accord
si tu t'y vas me je suis sûr qu'elle va
penser réellement que j'ai réellement
des pouvoirs ben c'est drôle ça me fera
sur quoi un stock d'affaires ça sur un
stade ok j'irai voir sinon jean bart que
ça cet été sur les plages c'est je le
fais ça aux gens pour gagner des sous
mais bien sûr et moi je prends 10 %
disent rien j'en ai fait trente
exemplaires de la terre encre bleue
merveilleuse tu veux à postuler pour
présenter détruites dans les émissions
de télé mais c'est parce que c'est ça
j'ai remarqué que souvent c'est ce que
tu me proposait dans des vidéos j'ai
trouvé je m'en sortais très bien avec
dans celles de juin non mais je rêvais
de faire c'était quoi
si la roue de la fortune n'hésitez pas à
acquérir ce merveilleux lot de jeu
fascinant énigmatique et bleu font la
qualité est indéniable
l'encré est particulièrement agréable à
l'oeil un jeu pour toute la famille afat
rattrape on va les offrir comme en ont
fait un concours
enfin concours ont fait un concours je
propose au peuple aux sétois qui les
fait gagner tu les fais tous gagnés sur
la chaîne moi je vais gagner
touati elle sort quand la vidéo qu'on a
fait ensemble
aujourd'hui le même jour aujourd'hui
elle sort aujourd'hui
alors on a fait une vidéo avec céline
sur sa chaîne qui est drôle enfin on a
fait beaucoup rire
il ya urgence à ma chance dans les
commentaires de sa vidéo sur sa chaîne
je vous mets le lien dans la description
vous mettez un hashtag le tac quoi on
met quoi acheter les achats acheter des
achats vous mettez le hashtag télé achat
dans les commentaires de la vidéo que
j'ai fait avec céline sur la chaîne de
céline h
on va dire d'ici une semaine tu fais le
tirage au sort c'est moi qui t'ai tirage
c'est moi qui tire au sort acheter les
achats et tu m'envoies les adresses et
moi je vous le poste est quoi qu'il
arrive que vous participiez ou pas vous
pouvez aussi dans la description
télécharger de toute manière tout pour
le faire vous même avec un petit mémo
qui reste plus que le tour peut être un
peu mieux que ce qu'on a fait la java du
manière un peu plus clair et tout donner
moi même mais c'était parfait j'ai
vraiment essayé faire au mieux pour vous
mais moi m'ont redonné je suis allé aux
toilettes pour m'abonner attache m c'est
toi tu sais si tu m'avais convaincu
c'est pour s'intéresser à toutes et tous
fait du coup je m'étouffe et oui ça
c'est clair je me suis amené portail
manuel sinon tu peux le mettre devant
toi c'est toi qui bouge la tête
céline ça fait longtemps que vous la
voyez sur la chaîne j'aime beaucoup ce
qu'a fait c'est une excellente humoriste
et je trouve ça génial qu'elle se soit
lancé sur youtube
j'aimerais la soutenir parce que je sais
qu'elle veut faire des tournages au
space etc
j'en appelle à vous pour aller chez
qu'est sa chaîne vous abonner cas puisse
encore nous produire d'encore plus
grosse vidéo fait ça soutenez-le à vous
aussi
c'est la première fois que vous demande
ça comme ça j'espère que vous le ferez
un petit rap des familles quoi avec un
peu de chance ça n'a pas désactiver les
notifications par mail de youtube à
chaque nouvel abonné
si on peut lui faire fumer son téléphone
je serai fier de vous et fiers de nous
n'oubliez pas de déposer un magnifique
effluents brillant pouce en l'air sur
cette vidéo
et puis et puis à très bientôt bah oui
voilà pensez à vous abonner aussi tout
ça chao et là c'est pas du mentalisme
c'est de la technologie parce que si tu
cliques sur le petit rond là que tu vois
même si depuis un téléphone une tablette
eh bien ça ta bonne à ma chaîne tu peux
tu abonnés comme ça à ma chaîne et ça ça
ça fait plaisir
où est la mienne ou à la tienne oui le
niveau cliquer aussi sur ta tête tu as
toi oui cliquez sur ma tête j'adore ça
[Musique]